throughout America's adventure in free
government our basic purposes have been
to keep the peace to foster progress in
human achievement and to enhance liberty
dignity and integrity among peoples and
among nations progress toward these
noble goals is persistently threatened
by the conflict now engulfing the world
it commands our whole attention absorbs
our very being global in scope atheistic
in character ruthless in purpose and
insidious in men unhappily the danger
imposes promises to be of young definite
duration to meet us successfully there
is call for not so much the emotional
and transitory sacrifices of crisis but
rather those which enable us to carry
forward steadily surely and without
complaint the burdens of a prolonged and
complex struggle with Liberty the state
crises they will continue to be in
meeting them whether foreign or domestic
great or small there is a recurring
temptation to feel that some spectacular
and costly actually could become the
miraculous solution to all current
difficulties but each proposal must be
weighed in the light of a broader
consideration the need to maintain
balance in and among national programs
balance between our essential
requirements as a nation and the duties
imposed by the nation upon the
individual balance between actions of
the moment and the national welfare of
the future good judgement seeks balance
and drumettes lack of it he eventually
finds imbalance and frustration you and
I my fellow citizens need to be strong
in our faith that all nations under God
will reach the goal of peace with
justice
may we be ever unswerving and devotion
to principle confident but humble with
power diligent in pursuit of the
nation's great goals